(audience cheers and applauds)
- Hey.
- [Kelly] Have y'all ever met before?
- No, but-
- We got a chance to
chop it up in the back.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- And, he told me he was gonna let me
reenact the scene
- That's right, yeah.
- that you was showing me.
- I'm gonna show him some stunts.
- I know. I'm like, man.
- Can I tell you something?
I've only ever been to
one basketball game.
- Yeah.
- And, I saw this man.
- Oh, really? That's
the one that you, yeah.
- The one basketball game was Knicks-Heat.
And, you guys won.
- Yeah, well.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- How we do. That's how we do.
- It had nothing to do
with me being there.
- Yeah, I think you were
the good luck charm.
- But, you know, I'm gonna
- take some credit.
- [Kelly] He has no talent over there
No. Were you into sports
growing up, though?
- Yeah, soccer.
- Like, so you're football?
- Football, yes.
- Yeah, so you're football.
- Yes.
- Yeah,
- I just did a translation, but.
- [Kelly] I know you were being nice.
- All my friends are gonna be like,
"What are you talking about?"
- I know, I know. America.
We just took the name and ran with it
with a different sport.
- You're welcome.
- A completely different game.
- I like it.
- Yeah.
- But, that's a hard one, though.
That's a lot of cardio,
soccer. Did you ever play?
- I did. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I played every single day.
- Oh, yeah.
- That's what I did.
- Every lunch break in the
morning, in the evening.
Yeah, I was obsessed.
- Oh, my God. Don't you?
- But, I wasn't an athlete.
- Well? What?
(audience laughs)
- That's why my dream
didn't come true, you know.
- Wait, wait, if you.
- You know,
- you have to work so hard.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] You do.
- But you were
- And, I did.
- playing every day.
(audience laughs)
If I'm playing every day, I'm
calling myself an athlete.
That's what I'm calling myself.
Wait, so, okay. So wait,
was there anything you ever grew up doing
that you loved, but you weren't good at?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Okay. We wanna hear that,
'cause you're so excellent at basketball.
What did you suck at Dwyane?
- Singing.
- [Kelly] Oh, singing?
- Yeah. Every day.
- Oh, now I wanna do
a "Kellyoke" with you.
- [Callum] Me too.
(all laugh)
- Every day. Terrible at it.
Every day.
- In the shower.
- Everywhere.
- [Kelly] Well, your daughter can sing.
- So she got it.
- Well, not from me.
- Okay. All right.
- That's Mama.
- Well explain the show, "Masters
of the Air" for everybody.
- "Masters of the Air"
is about the bombers
that came over to England in World War II.
Who saved the world.
You know, these guys are
real life superheroes.
They put themselves in the
most volatile situations
known to mankind.
You know, 77% of these
guys went down, you know.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah, it's the most violent atmosphere
ever known to mankind.
And, what's beautiful about the show
is you get to experience that,
you see them in the skies,
and it's gory, it's horrible.
But then, you see them
come back down to earth,
and deal with that trauma and that grief.
And, we would call that PTSD now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They didn't know what that was.
And, they had to somehow
find it inside themselves
to get back up, and go again.
- Yeah. It's amazing
what we asked of people
without knowing, you know, what it was.
- Yeah. Look, we wouldn't
be here without them.
You know, I definitely wouldn't, I know.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So you get to play a soldier.
So little known fact about me,
I used to steal my brothers GI Joes,
and I loved playing with soldiers.
They never thought girls wanted do that.
I did, with the Barbies.
And, the Barbies were
gigantic compared to them.
- They got along?
- Yes. Yeah.
- It was harmonious?
- No,
- the Barbies annihilated them, yeah.
(all laugh)
But I played with GI
Joes, as like a soldier.
But I hear that you
have a fun action figure
that you grew up with.
It wasn't that y'all, you
didn't grow up with GI Joe,
you grew up with what?
- No, we had
- Action Man was what it was called.
- Action Man.
- Action man. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It does what it says on the tin.
(audience laughs)
- It's very self-explanatory.
- I also had Street Sharks.
- We heard you like Street Sharks.
And, I often buy toys a
lot, 'cause I have kids.
So we've got
- No way.
- some Street Sharks for you.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my God.
- We found those for you.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, you want one?
- Yeah.
- I'm not even kidding.
My Barbie would've whooped
their behinds, too.
- For sure.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] If they were just bigger.
- Look this guy's got the
roller skates and everything.
- Exactly.
- All right.
- They look fancy. I like that.
We didn't have that.
(Dwyane mimics punching noise)
All right, well let's
take another quick break.
Beating himself up?
It's a lot of therapy there.
Okay. Callum's new series,
"Masters of the Air"
is streaming now. It's incredible.
It's on Apple TV+. Y'all
gotta check it out.